as the child grows and as you as a
parent train that child then more
freedom should be granted to make their
own decisions I feel like you train a
dog and not a kid I think train is a
good word I don't want to train child
okay
why do Maryland parents are accused of
child neglect after allowing their two
kids to walk home alone from a park
about a mile away I see a wide range
within free-range parenting but parents
that basically let their kids do
whatever they want and I see that as a
recipe for disaster when I think of a
strict parent I think of someone who
might be more concerned with the
behavior of the child than the heart of
the child I actually do consider myself
strict but I want to be emotionally
conscious we've been told by this
oppressive
safety obsessed terrified Society that
you can never let your kid do anything
on their own maybe till they're like 36
it's a luxury to be a free-range parent
because there's a certain privilege that
goes with that being a strict parent I
think first of all I imagine stress
should be a really fun time of your life
why follow all these rules when you want
to enjoy your kids
[Music]
hi I'm Hal chafey I have five kids I'm a
minister and we live in Maryland I'm
Christian I am a birth and postpartum
doula as well as the newborn care
specialist I have one daughter who is
seven
hi I'm Jenny Atkins I have two daughters
I'm a health coach and I wrote a
children's healthy cookbook
my name is Winn I live in Los Angeles
I've one child so my chef restaurateur
author I'm Jody and I'm the CEO of the
Madden house and I have eight children
and I'm from LA hi to everybody
I'm Lenore scan Daisy I'm the mother of
two and I founded the book blog and
movement free-range kids
surprise I founded the free range kids
movement I let my nine-year-old ride the
subway in New York City by himself I
wrote a column and two days later I was
on The Today Show MSNBC Fox News and NPR
defending my parenting style and I
started free range kids that weekend as
a blog to say look I believe in safety I
just don't think that we have to you
know you have a security detail every
time we let our kids out of the house
[Music]
see you later for a friend children
should be trusted to make their own
decisions
so of course children should make their
own decisions I mean we're trying to
raise them to be responsible adults if
they don't make decisions they'll never
learn when my child is possibly going to
make a bad decision what I want to do is
not tell them it's a bad decision I
think that's the wrong thing to do
because then ultimately I can I reject
that anyway also it depends on what
we're talking about decisions about like
if it's bedtime and you want your kids
to be in bed at 8 o'clock I think that
is up to you but I remember a time my
son called me he was 10 at the time and
he said mom can I have another piece of
banana bread I thought I felt I felt bad
because of course that's a very simple
decision they expected that I was the
one to decide almost everything about
what they were eating and doing and I
felt like there was something wrong and
that actually started me reevaluating
thing didn't can they climb the tree
just let him climb the tree and what's
the worst that can happen they break an
arm oh well well for my kids
specifically she can go outside and play
after school and she can draw she can do
whatever but there is a very healthy
boundary like we don't have the type of
health care that most people have so
like no you can't climb the tree if it's
like oh I don't want to play violin
anymore but it's like you can't you're
not allowed to quit things that you
start because even as an adult you
become a flaky adult well you see so
many parents nowadays who just like been
to every whim of their child children
should be trusted to make their own
decisions when it is wise for them to
make their own decisions you know I'm
not gonna let my five-year-old decide
that he's not gonna brush his teeth
anymore because he doesn't you know as
the child grows and as you as a parent
train that child then more freedom
should be granted to make their own
decisions it should be our children I
feel like you train a dog and not a kid
I think train is a good word I don't
want a trained child ok well I do I want
to maybe not like me yeah do you think
you need to train them to be respectful
or do you think that you guide them in a
way to learn to be respectful because of
the decisions they've chosen Oh
I try to be as biblical as I can when it
comes to parenting I know a lot of
people would disagree on that but I have
five kids and I'd do my best to follow
it I found so much wisdom and it's
worked don't really follow rules even if
it's a theory of free range parenting
per se if you're following those
free-range parenting rules then you you
become strict and I don't think that
there should be rules it should be
whatever the day brings kids deserve
privacy even they're not adults are
still people and they need time to
either hear the thoughts or process
things or just they need a sense of
comfort in solitude and things that are
are sacred to them so I don't have any
teenagers yet there's no way I mean
there's no way that I'm not gonna have
access to their cellphone that that's
not gonna happen but they want time
alone I think that's fine and they
should have that and it's healthy to do
that
the reason I hesitated is because I
think back to my childhood there were
things that happened sometimes that can
last with you for the rest of your life
you know people can be abused online now
so when I have that parent spidey sense
if something's not right here and my
kids can like no you can't have my cell
phone yes I can in our household
we live by this kind of thought live
your life in such a way that if everyone
could see what you're doing in private
that you wouldn't be ashamed so you can
sell my kids also look through my phone
privacy is not something a child should
be entitled to have do we give our kids
quiet downtime yes am I looking for
their stuff no um I actually agree with
the definition of downtime and privacy
at my house there's no privacy because
you don't pay any bills
she also trusts me and I wanted to make
a relationship to where she trusts me
that even if she came to tell me like
there's no
I'm yelling I don't screaming I'm doing
things like that we're very open but
there is no privacy so I just wanted to
put in a plea though for some privacy
you know I go around and I talk about
free range kids and sometimes what I ask
the audience is to tell me when
something did go wrong and I ask them
did you tell your parents what do you
think I said why do you think they said
it fear of what you think it's trouble
they said they didn't want their freedom
taken away I think it's important though
that we hold our children accountable
because in the world there are plenty of
adults who are not held accountable
who've never been held accountable and
they just do things that are terrible
but most of childhood is little things
and you don't have to be there for
everyone because that's when kids start
realizing I can handle this privilege
the ability to just do things without
any repercussions or Consequences as a
black person or a person of color we
sometimes just don't have the privilege
to allow our children to be free range
although I would love for her to be free
spirit and just do and be she can't
because black kids get murdered in the
street no idea this is a hard hard for
me my job is not to be my kid's friend
it's to be their parent but I don't
think that is mutually exclusive of not
being their friend either if that makes
any sense but I prioritize very being
the parent parental unit me and my mom I
would say that she's my best friend but
like as as a child it was she was my mom
and I hope to have that type of relation
with my daughter but right now I'm the
parent and you're the child because I
don't want you to lose respect for me
like I'm not gonna go clubbin with my
daughter like there's just some things
that I'm just not gonna do that I do
with my friends but I'm not gonna do it
Mike
I agreed that I'm their mom first but
I'm also their friend I'm also someone
that they trust and admire and they come
to and I listen to them and I give them
my opinions and we have forged a
friendship but it's not without my
position as the authority in their life
their provider their comfort their mama
in my mind once my kids are 18 or let's
just say moved out of the house they are
an adult and at that point I want to
stop parenting if I haven't parented
enough by the time they're 18 then I
then that was my chance I don't want to
be a parent after 18 and when it comes
to clubbing I hope that when my kid is
old and grown up and they're going out
for a beer at a bar or whatever they're
doing of course I want to come with them
but here's the thing I just wanna say on
the other side of that is that we never
stopped growing up I mean man I don't
have parents I wish I did there's some
times where I just I wish I could just
ask for help I mean my grandmother just
passed away in me and I remember like
just feeling like what am I gonna do and
and that was not a friend moment that
was me hiding like a little child on her
lap because we've been crying and
needing that do that oh you're gonna do
this I guess I just want this right you
know I want them to be very independent
with your own mother do you have a
mother and if you do do you ever just
need your mama
sometimes ever does really you don't
need to like no get hug firmly I speak
to her like she's my friend
okay yeah and I think I spoke to her as
my friend when I was growing up as well
because she never she didn't parent I
had no rules I'm not so that explains a
lot when you talk about your philosophy
it's really a first-hand account where
maybe some of the rest of us are like
exploring how we might want to parent
but we all raise our children probably
according to a little bit of how we will
be were really know what we wished had
been different and then there's so many
societal influences growing up without
the security of knowing who I was and
knowing that I was dearly loved and
cherished by my mother and father was
soul-crushing for me as a mother I have
the opportunity to raise up a new
generation of healthy whole individuals
who are able to go forth and create new
families of their own and be a light in
this world and that's really what my
hope is my children what I don't want to
get involved at all yeah do we have to I
don't even want to stand back here but
is it gonna show our position like
standing back or City we do see you guys
in the background but we just want to
hear his perspective then people can
walk forward but if you don't want to
participate in the conversation
whatsoever you don't have to Wow yeah so
I'm kind of sad that nobody else walked
forward because not only do I think it's
an acceptable form of punishment but I
think it's one of the best and the
reason is is because it's effective it's
quick it's over it's done and the kid
can go off and play again and not have
to sit in the corner languish in a room
or something like that and it's not
about getting angry I'm mad I'm gonna
whack my kid
no it's about okay you made him you did
something you weren't supposed to do and
you're going to get spanked for this
so I'm gonna ask any of my disagrees who
wish to step forward to talk about this
please do if you wish not to step
forward you don't have to the specific
antic I have is for my child is one time
like you know as a parent you can lose
your patience and that happens we would
just kind of like slap him on the hand
we did something like they'll do that
don't do that and I remember one time he
did something and he started becoming
more self-aware and he started hitting
himself on the hand and hitting himself
and I was like I can't do this is hey we
can't go down this path with him this is
not gonna work for at least specifically
for him and I think it's a case-by-case
basis to like you know you've led your
kids in a way that hopefully he doesn't
lash out into the real world I don't
want him to react like that to someone
else either and I just feel like that's
my responsibility so yeah and you know I
hear that a opponents to spanking will
say I don't want my child to be violent
yeah you know I have five kids 10 and
under and the exact opposite is true
because they think it's a bad memory for
them what's that do you think they're
gonna have memories of these times being
spanked and that it will be sure
something is thankful for it I would do
because I mean I would be lying if I
said I never have spanked my child of
course sweet but I don't ever I don't
don't feel good about it don't you want
to raise your child to not want to do
things because they feel as if they'll
be a better person not because they're
going to be punished for it both see
this is hard for me to understand
because I come from a culture where
everyone like all my friends have loving
parents that spanked them as kids and
now they've grown up to be great
functional functional adults who respect
their parents and are glad their parents
spank them okay I'm is until say my my
view so I don't spank my child one
because of chattel slavery and Jim Crow
I'm black person and I live in a world
where black people are beaten all the
time I have a mother who spanked me I'd
I'm not glad that I was spanked I
respect her but I'm not happy about that
also the same thing with the people who
are like I was spanked I came out right
they usually have like anger issues
they're violent they whip their
kids they probably need therapy usually
they don't even realize how you mostly
[ __ ] up they are well you got to
understand it's parenting is more than
just I spank alright don't spank if
you're a terrible parent and you think
that spanking is gonna fix your kid
you're wrong I sometimes fear I am
raising my children the wrong way I
think part of parenting is always
worrying I mean as hard as I try to do
the right things you know there's always
doubts in your mind that you've done
something wrong I love to tell parents
especially new ones that we're all
winging it we're making mistakes every
day but the good thing about it is that
our kids still love us they still look
at us like mommy and so black parenting
is literally just like one huge ass
experiment people think that I the
answer because I wrote free range kids
and I run this let grow and all I can
say is that believing in your kids you
know believing in them
whether you give them a timeout or
you're speaking and believing that your
kids have this capacity for for being a
decent human being and they're gonna
make mistakes they're gonna be okay
that's what kids want so first of all I
think that parents are too hard on
themselves and you know what ultimately
your children are gonna make their own
decisions for me I don't I don't wonder
about whether or not I'm raising my kids
right because I try to raise my kids
according to what the Bible says
and so I have a guide that I that I fall
short fulfilling all the time but I look
to it as my guide and so just a few
simple guidelines if you follow and you
love your kid you care about them and
spend time with them then ultimately
they're gonna be okay I just love my
kids so much
and I give them 110 % one of the neat
things that I'm giving my kids it's a
little bit different is a mother and
father who are married and faithful to
one another
which I didn't have that and so it's it
makes me feel really good that I'm
giving them that I know that I'll never
just be totally set in my ways and be
unwilling to to change and to become a
better mother so I will never give up
growing myself the one piece of
parenting advice I give everyone is
don't listen to all the advice because
the beautiful thing about parenting is
is not what you're teaching your child
but sometimes what you're learning with
your child I think we all just want the
same things everybody wants their
children to be confident and secure in
their love it's just a lot of fun to
have kids and I always tell people I
said if you want to be a happier person
have more kids because kids are just so
much fun